et alors que les combats se poursuivent
cette lueur d'espoir peut-être volodymyr
zen ce qui le président ukrainien se dit
prêt à des compromis pour mettre fin aux
combats des compromis sur le statut du
dombass et de la crimée dans le même
temps les pourparlers se poursuivent
moscou les juges je cite pas assez
conséquent le président ukrainien lui
prévient quel que soit le résultat de
ces éventuel compromis seront soumis à
référendum on écoute
nous allons devoir parler des
modifications constitutionnelles
modifications
devant charles et dans tous les cas ce
sera décidé non pas seulement par le
précédent mais c'est la région qui rasa
selon ce sera décidé par le parlement
est très peur d'une craignant toute
façon on peut pas faire long
traoré ferrando main au référendum